Hello there, I'm Gav
I'm Dan.
Now, you may have noticed that, A,
we are the Slo Mo Guys, and B,
we are very hairy.
Very hairy.
I'm half Italian. What're you?
Me too.
You're half Italian too?
Yeah.
Between us, we are one Italian man.
I know what to do about that.
Yeah?
I've got a microwaveable waxing kit here,
how about we do something about it, and
wax and film it in slo-mo?
Have you ever wanted
to see hairs fly out of
skin in super slo-mo?
Oh, I have, actually, yeah.
Me too.
I think it would be disgusting.
Sure it will be filth.
Filth.
Let's film it.
Thoughts?
I don't want to wax my leg.
Well, it's high up, no
one is going to see it.
Well here, well I've got a tan here.
Well that's 'cause you wear short shorts!
Yeah!
It's not Italy in the eighties, D!
Yeah, but I wear short shorts, so I don't
want a patch os skin just like--
People will think I've got a
square of alopecia on my leg.
Oh God.
All right.
All right, you ready?
Go for it.
Bugger!
That was--
Ah, look at my leg! It's gone all red--
That's not bad! That's very good!
God!
That's incredible!
Gosh! Ah!
Okay well, that's a decent looking shot,
but I want to get a lot closer, just
to see if I can see individual hairs.
Now, sadly, I don't have a
macro-lens, and this lens'
minimum focus is about
here, and I wanna be
focusing here. Not the end of the world.
There's a trick you can do,
you just pull the lens off,
flip it around, try and cover the hole as
best you can, not let
any light in, and now my
minimum focus is around here.
What?
It's a nifty trick.
I didn't know that was a thing.
Yeah!
That's impressive. I
actually learned something.
That's cool!
Yeah!
Can you-- all right!
Now the downside is, I
can't actually use this
focus ring anymore or the
aperture, so I'm going
to have to preset those
and just tilt in and out
with the actual camera itself.
And push the button.
And trigger the camera, so--
we have a mission, this one, but
we'll see what we can get.
That's cool. I hope it works.
Yeah.
Three, two, one-
Ready?
Okay, hit it!
Dan, it's always you who gets all the fun.
The fun?
Yep.
I got waxed! I got, like--
look at my legs!
I wanna get waxed.
All right. Get ready.
Here we go.
A slop of that.
Slop it there.
Slop it!
Okay, ready?
Yep.
One, two , three.
Does it hurt?
It really does hurt!
Yeah!
God!
Well, Dan, that was just as
disgusting as I hoped it'd be.
And painful.
And painful. Yours is bleeding.
Yeah, little tiny bits of blood.
Mine is, ah,
oh.
Looks like chicken skin.
Mine looks like a plucked chicken.
It does!
And yours looks like blood beef.
I don't want to do that ever again.
People are going to give
me such weird looks.
The most amazing thing, to me, about that,
aside from the hair getting plucked out,
was how the skin just hovers up in the air
after it's been plucked.
Yeah.
Like, there's so much give in the skin
and it ripples so much.
In slo-mo it lasts so much longer as well.
Yeah.
It looks like the skin is
completely distorted for ages.
Yeah.
It's weird.
A formed hump that
eventually settles back down.
That was quite cool. That
was very fascinating.
Yeah.
Hopefully you enjoyed
that video, feel free
to follow us on Twit-oid.
We have a second channel
that you can subscribe
to, that's quite good.
There's a behind-the-scenes on there--
Couple of FAQ's.
Couple of questions,
we're filling it up as
much as we can, and buy some
merch, if you'd like to!
Yeah!
Thank you very much for watching,
we'll see you in a few weeks!